welcome to who's there a show about
cloud identity
[Music]
and the last episode of who's there I
talked about why identity platform is
awesome and how to enable it in your GCP
project today I'm showing you how to
integrate identity platform into your
JavaScript web app if you haven't
enabled identity platform yet I
recommend you check out the last episode
of who's there before proceeding you
also need a web page that uses
JavaScript and if web development
doesn't happen to be your jam then check
out the getting started videos for iOS
and Android both linked below alright
with the prerequisites out of the way
let's get started in the cloud console
for my project I selected the identity
platform tab I previously added email
and password authentication if you
haven't added this yet click add a
provider and select email password there
are lots of other providers to explore
but today I'm just sticking with this
one on this providers page you see a
link in the upper right for application
setup details this pops up a window with
brief getting started information you
see copy and paste the snippet below at
the bottom of your HTML before other
script tags learn more go ahead and
click learn more this takes you to a
guide on getting started with firebase
authentication on websites if you used
firebase before you probably have some
experience with this documentation but
it's entirely possible you've never even
heard of firebase let alone use it so
let's talk about firebase for a moment
firebase is a suite of products to help
you build your app and grow your user
base it includes SDKs for Objective C
and Swift for iOS Java and Kotlin for
Android JavaScript for web as well as
several web frameworks like angular
there are game specific SDKs too for
unity and C++ and so much more I can
make a whole series of videos just on
firebase but fortunately the firebase
team has already done that if you're
interested in finding out more check out
the documentation and the firebase
YouTube channel both linked below so in
many ways firebase is the perfect
complement to Google cloud and very
broadly speaking Google cloud products
focus on server-side solutions like
App Engine compute engine cloud
functions Cooper Nettie's engine and
CloudFront and fire based products focus
on client-side solutions like client
authentication Cloud messaging cloud
storage for firebase and so on now I
meant that it's challenging to pin down
the relationship between Google cloud
and firebase my oversimplified
explanation is that firebase is a way to
access some Google cloud platform
products from a client application
specifically for identity platform
this explanation works well the firebase
auth SDKs enable you to access identity
platform functionality from your client
app so with that in mind let's head back
to that firebase documentation add the
script as instructed in the configure
your application instructions in the
cloud console and that's it now you can
use the firebase off SDK to sign up log
in log out and get user info about an
identity platform user identity platform
gives you access to many different login
providers including federated identity
providers like Google Facebook and
Twitter and you can enable several login
methods for a single app allowing your
users to authenticate the way that they
prefer some of these login methods may
require additional steps which are
listed in the console when you enable
that login method see the documentation
below for information on how to
implement other login providers for now
let's get back to implementing email and
password login in the cloud console
create a fake user with a test email and
test password of course you can also
create a new user from the client but
this here is a good way to get up and
running right away see how to create a
user in your web app following the link
below sign in your fake user firebase
off method sign in with email and
password this function returns a promise
that when result is a user credential
object if there is no error you can do
whatever you need to do with the user
right now just log the users UID or
display the UID in a div include a catch
block to handle any errors so it's clear
that
my example thus far is not a complete
oscillation you need a way for users to
create user accounts handle password
resets and logout and each of these
functions needs some UI development as
well if you prefer you can write all of
this functionality yourself using the
firebase guides as a reference but you
also have the option to use the firebase
author ID module this open source UI was
created by US Special estat Google it
includes all of the views you would need
to implement for account creation login
logout and password reset functionality
you can incorporate auth UI in just a
few lines of code personally whenever I
start a new project I use firebase UI
first so I can focus on the key features
of my app while still protecting data
through authentication whether you make
your own UI or use firebase UI you will
very likely need to know the OP status
before performing many app actions for
example you're going to want to check if
there is a user logged in before trying
to write to a database that's where
getting the current user comes into play
let's look at how to implement this
functionality for each of your app's
pages that need information about the
signed-in user attach an observer to the
Global authentication object this
observer gets called whenever the user
sign-in state changes attach the
observer using the on/off state changed
method when a user successfully signs in
you can get information about the user
in the observer then add the function
that logs out so you can see the state
change listed our closure be triggered
again of course it's really unusual to
log in only to immediately log out but
this is purely for the sake of example
so you can see state change listener get
triggered when you run the app check the
console the console logs show that the
user is logged in and then they are
logged out congratulations you just
added identity platform to a web app
ready to see what else like that any
platform can do check out the firebase
author web guides auth QuickStart code
and firebase YouTube channel and be sure
to subscribe to the Google cloud
platform channel so you can be the first
to know about new
in the who's there series thanks for
watching and let's see you on a future
episode
[Music]